information and you know it makes me
angry or sad is more it that that the
work of an artist over thirty years you
think they think that we just pull that
out of their ass and that they can copy
it you know without the artist they can
copy it you mean your show I do yeah and
it it is you know all the stuff I
suffered in my life I put into that show
that show is about my family my children
and it's just like wow that it's so huge
it's so huge it's it's beyond entitled
but what are they gonna what is their
plan and how are they able to do that
did you let them yeah I signed off Why
ask me - why'd you sign off because I
felt like I would be a huge hypocrite to
have talked thirty years or more in my
life about labor rights and the rights
of working people if I took away those
people two hundred people's jobs so
that's why I did it I wanted him to work
I know how they had planned on another
season and they probably I'd already
spend the money was there any
consideration of redemption was there
any path where they could allow you to
apologize or do something that would
endear yourself to the people were they
offered that I said let me go on all
your ABC shows and explain my tweet and
how it was a political and not a racial
tweet and you know that was denied me
it's like you can't say anything till
you sign off you can't say anything
until you sign off so they wanted you to
sign off the rights and then they would
have you do whatever you wanted to do go
on their interview shows no they didn't
guarantee that they didn't guarantee
that so they just wanted you to sign off
and they offered you nothing in return
they offered me some money but the idea
was just to be able to redo the show
yeah to take all those years of my ideas
and how I thought of twenty years of
those situations to come back it took me
20 years to figure how would these
characters where would they be now and I
did that by living among
regular and normal people for 20 years I
never lived behind you know racially
segregated gates like other stars I
lived in working people for
neighborhoods and I farm around farmers
and I wasn't gonna be that big of a
hypocrite like macadamia nut farm
I sure do it's gorgeous you should come
and see it I love to come see it I love
the Big Island isn't it gorgeous amazing
people are done there though today you
know what I read some people some lady
took a boat full of people too close to
the volcano to look at it and and the
lava overtook their boat and thank God
none were killed but they were got like
about two feet up on the girl oh jesus
oh don't do that hole Diane's don't do
that somebody got hit with a that's
probably why it's pretty good weed yeah
they got hit by a flying chunk of rock
from the volcano on one of the boats -
they were having lava tourism and
someone getting clipped by a rock it's
so not smart it's so stupid it's a
dangerous dangerous situation shouldn't
we don't go on those tools is your area
safe my my area flooded a bit I had to
replace my roads for about the 10th time
in ten years I always got to replace my
roads I really got into making roads
that's one thing that I really did enjoy
yes I'll be headed back there and be
making more Road so I'm excited about it
I can cut a road like nobody's business
joking I'm a hell of AI want to write a
book my granny is a scout and because I
do scout the jungle you know and make a
road in there I love the attitude of
people that live in a big island it's a
very relaxed laid-back friendly attitude
they just have all the time in the world
it's a different sort of vibe when you
go there yeah everybody helps their
neighbors there they don't like turn
them in yeah you know everybody helps
out their neighbors and their neighbors
are like every every kind of people you
can think of it's very very diverse
cultural how'd you wind up macular well
I went there because my son buck I had I
made him go to the school
so then I bought a place right by the
school because this kid you know he had
feel he's 23 now so he won't get mad but
he had some severe ADHD there so I had
to do what I did to get him now he just
graduated from college he's doing real
good
yes yeah he's my first college grad
mm-hmm all right
ADHD maybe he's a comic yeah he's so
funny oh my god he's so hilarious maybe
is he's a comic just wait so sure it's
all my grandkids are - they're all yeah
video that you showed me yes they're all
hilarious yeah they seem very funny what
are they gonna do to your character on
the show they're gonna kill you off yeah
I think they did didn't tell me someone
might know they didn't tell me how weird
is this some of my spies told me how
weird is it they're taking you out of
Roseanne they're calling it the Connors
it's all going on without you being
there what does that feel like um it's a
mind warp and a mind [ __ ] you know so
I'm just trying all from one tweet yeah
I misunderstood tweet I misunderstood
tweet while you're on ambien why are you
drunk deal I wasn't drunk only had like
one or two beers well when you have one
or two beers with ambien yeah I guess
you're drunk you're [ __ ] up I was yeah
I wasn't in and smile I thought - right
no I don't think I'd smoke pot then mmm
no I didn't smoke pot then I was at my
mom's house puffing on the cigs I went
down in the basement
I was hiding down there in the basement
because they were surrounding my mom's
house paparazzi's and such and says I
down in the basement and that's where I
always used to go when I was like 13 and
I found this stuff and chalk on the on
the walls of the basement there that I
remembered right when I was 13
and then I found an old butt from one I
snuck cigs when I started smoking oh
hell yeah it smoked good but I was
hiding down there smoking they were
knocking on my mom's door and I was like
oh my god so my boyfriend got the door
he's like a big man you know he's like
may I help you
you know that's my man character and I
thought they were gonna you know say
something and they're like we just
please tell Roseann we love her and you
know we don't like this and blah blah
and that was happening all the time and
that's when I was like geez I've never
ever felt this kind of affection from
people in all my career so it's kind of
a cool that's that's the thing there's
the social media outrage and then
there's a people in real life that feel
terrible for you because they feel like
you got a raw deal yeah they think that
there's Delta there there are so many
double standards of people who said
things on the air remember I just said
it to a small population less than
600,000 people on Twitter but these
people say things on the air and they
are not well I know Joe I had to call
pants and apologize so yeah what did Joy
Behar say about pence that was so bad
she something about his Christian faith
yeah that they're psychotic or something
cuz they so she called Fiona's yeah
that's what I heard you know an apology
with your network behind you really
works like with what's-her-name that
called Ivanka the names I can't know
Samantha bee yeah and her network was
behind her and that was far more
offensive Anna was on the air and but
when your network is not behind you that
you don't really and they won't without
me the thing about its they were they
didn't want me to tweet the whole the
whole truth is I I told him I wasn't
going to tweet and you know I promised
him over and over and although they
never send it in writing which was
required but anyway they called my
publicist
unloaded on him all the time and you
know I should have stayed off Twitter I
did it to myself and you know I made a
mistake and and the ball kept rolling
but it's just crazy the